ja ich habe ein bisschen gestaunt weil
wir immer darüber diskutieren heute
aktuell armin laschet macht den weg frei
für einen moderierten prozess anstoßen
es ist möglich sich aber denn frei mal
in religion ja
er macht ihnen frei aber geht trotzdem
erhobenen hauptes weiterhin in
klassischer laschet die union ist in der
krise in einem ganz bedauernswerten
zustand alle parteien sind sich einig
über den riesigen reformbedarf des
landes und die kanzlerin die 16 jahre
regiert hat und 20 jahre cdu vorsitzende
war
entweder nicht zu sehen oder sie blickt
stumm auf dem ganzen tisch herum man
fragt sich so ein bisschen warum spricht
eigentlich niemand über das erbe der
kanzlerin wir haben eine erstarkte afd
die nach der migrationswelle 2015 sich
festgesetzt hat im parteiensystem und
auch bei der bundestagswahl wieder ganz
klare zehn prozent plus bekommen hat
auch darüber wäre zu reden und man merkt
eigentlich wenig man merkt in nostalgie
also viele leute sagen wir werden sie
vermissen das sagen gerade leute die sie
nie gewählt haben und man wundert sich
ein bisschen war woher diese stille es
ist ein interessantes phänomen dass die
kompetenzzuweisung für die kanzlerin
meistens eine sehr persönliche ist wenn
man dann nämlich nachfragt was genau
imponiert ihr denn was sind denn die
punkte die sie hinterlassen wird dann
kommt relativ wenig und sie wird
geschätzt als mensch als typ für ihre
allüren losigkeit alles prima aber
trotzdem würde mich doch interessieren
was sind eigentlich die dinge die
bleiben von der ära merkel und da sieht
es sehr dürftig aus kurioser höhepunkt
ist ein buch angela merkel die großen
reden vor wurden die koffer natürlich
deutschen zeitung und er steigt
eigentlich damit ein dass er sagt naja
große reden hat es eigentlich gar nicht
gehalten verrichten und der meinung
sagen und der kernsatz in diesem vorwort
was ja ein liebevolles leitwort sein
sollte der kernsatz ist das problem bei
den reden von angela merkel ist das
zuhören da schildert minutiös wo sie
sich immer fast bit und so weiter in
diesen reden findet sich eine von 2006
deutsche einheit ihre erste rede zu
solchen einer 2006 darin beklagt sie
bürokratie und selbstgewissheit
selbstzufriedenheit der deutschen und
was haben wir zum 1 der kanzlerschaft in
der pandemie gesehen bürokratie
überbordende selbstzufriedenheit die
beim ersten test auf 1 auseinander
fliegt das ist schon beachtlich dass
sich in diesen 16 jahren so wenig getan
hat und alle wir sind aber nostalgisch
unterwegs und sagen ja große kanzlerin
nicht kratzen eine sehr berechtigte
frage stellung finde ich wobei ich sagen
wir denn das ist nicht 16 jahre lang
stillstand gewesen anfangs war gab es ja
noch ein reformwillen sie hat ja bevor
sie kanzlerin war vergisst man hier an
der humboldt-uni eine unglaubliche
aufrührerische reform regalen alles muss
anders werden tja ja ging halt ja also
fahren im gefolge von kohle und dann ist
alles anders geworden heute ist das land
total erstaunt deshalb spende ich stimme
ich der these total zu aber zur merkel
ii sierung deutschlands gehört eben auch
dass die medien auch merkel ii siert
sind also wenn ein prominenter
journalist ein buch herausgibt über die
großen reden angela merkel wir keine
einzige gehört haben und immer wenn sie
im bundestag eine regierungserklärung
abgegeben hat konnte man dem nachbarn
sagen weg mich wenn es vorbei ist dann
die daten wurden dann interessant danach
das ist schon ein zeichen
einer eines absinkenden
kritischen bewusstseins in dem land und
das muss jetzt wieder zum leben erweckt
werden dazu gehört übrigens auch dass
man sich mal dass irgendwelche fernsehen
angucken muss was ich da so abspielt da
muss auch viel zum leben erweckt werden
aber darüber reden wir nochmal
nein man muss aber auch dazu sagen
angela merkel kann jetzt aus zwei großen
koalitionen und sie das hat sich
irgendwie geschafft sich selbst und ihre
partei einfach von allen kanten zu
befreien alles so schön abgeschliffen
dass die partei jetzt nicht mal wusste
wofür sie steht wir haben jetzt hast du
bei den in draußen bei der bevölkerung
hast du anlage hat das eine lager die
merkel total mögen und die dieses weiter
so wollen dieses weiter so dass auch
irgendwo darauf gewitzelt hat auf sie
kennen mich naja das hat sich gezeigt
die bundesbürger kennen anscheinend olaf
scholz teil der regierung bisher besser
als armin laschet und mit dem verbinden
sie auch dieses diesem sicherheitsaspekt
das weiter so das läuft ja schon uns
aber gleichzeitig hat armin laschet
dieses ist dieses kunststück gelungen
das all der frust über das was liegen
geblieben ist all diese dieser mief und
die cdu h wir sind doch nicht so
zufrieden mit den letzten jahren das hat
lacht wird jetzt abbekommen naja gut man
darf die partei die cdu und die csu als
schwesterparteien natürlich nicht aus
der verantwortung entlassen man erinnere
sich 2015 migrations krise es brodelt in
der partei in der fraktion wurde täglich
der aufstand geprobt nie vollzogen aber
immer geprobt und am ende des jahres
hielt merkel eine rede auf dem parteitag
und elf minuten applaus schalten ihr
entgegen obwohl man vorher sogar
wolfgang schäuble noch angetragen hatte
doch möglicherweise gegen die kanzlerin
zu putschen also auch diese konformitäts
effekte die man da sieht sind mir als
ehemaligem ddr bürger schon sehr sehr
ängstlich sehr kluge beobachtungen der
erinnerung das hatte was
nordkoreanisches ich war auf allen
parteitagen und da wurde den delegierten
immer gesagt lange applaudieren die
journalisten messen das und das stimmt
ja auch da standen wir alle da gucken
auf ihre armbanduhr wie lange gibt es
jetzt applaus und dann hatte man sich
vorher schon erkundigt um dann nachher
meldungen schalten zu können wie lange
warten beim letzten mal der applaus war
ein letzte mal waren neun minuten da
müssen wir diesmal elf minuten so hat
sich das abgespielt und
ihm eigen und die mutigen unter den
abgeordneten die gingen raus ja es ist
eine vermeidungsstrategie kenne ich auch
aus dem osten das hatte ich eigentlich
da hatte ich mehr selbstbewusstsein und
erhobenem haupt mir eigentlich einer
freien gesellschaft aber auch
tatsächlich von angela merkel auch nicht
schlecht aber ich stimme zu in der these
der entpolitisierung der fdp was genau
in der entpolitisierung der debatte das
ist ja der punkt wahlen ende dann auch
die leute sagen ja ich finde dass diesen
humor ganz gut und aus bodenständiger
und die mutti das ist ja wieso auf
einmal diese ganzen werte zählen und
wieso olaf scholz sich ja auch sogar so
selbst inszeniert hat als merkel
nachfolge bis er dann sogar die raute
nach gemacht hat weil die bevölkerung
auch so ein bisschen die debattenkultur
verloren hat unter angela merkel in der
analyse stimme ich zu an anderen punkt
den ich aber auch noch interessant finde
ich will jetzt keine politikberatung für
andere parteien machen wollen ja alle in
anderen politischen zielen dieser nager
sein
eine sache auch wenn ich selbst
vorsitzender einer organisation bin es
ist ja auch immer
aufgabe zu gucken was ist eigentlich
nach mehr gibt es dort persönlichkeiten
wie geht es meiner partei danach ich
meine sie hat ja auch unglaublich von
der cdu profitiert hat sie an kern aber
so einen richtigen plan wie geht es
eigentlich nach mehr weiter der erste
ist gescheitert mit ak aber danach war
der einzige plan sich merz weiter zu
verhindern und die sind das nicht
fortzuführen aber ich glaube das ist
eine debatte die die cdu schon aufführen
muss er haben sie um erneuerung
diskutieren möchte wie hat angela merkel
was hat wie ist unsere partei geworden
wohl überall steht besteht überhaupt
bedarf zu modernisieren das hat ja auch
gesagt er will die partei wieder
modernisieren aber es war wieder so
unkonkret dass niemand wusste was
bedeutet das und ich glaube das ist
kernproblem dieser partei die muss zum
teil erst mal eine tiefe analyse rein
erstens diesen berühmten satz sie kennen
mich der stammt nicht von ihr der sie
erfunden worden von einem sehr klugen
berater der sie auf dieses kanzler duell
vorbereitet hat sowas wird ja geprobt
denn die situation im konkreten fall da
hat sie dann angefangen war das war die
frage war ja warum soll man sie wieder
wählen und dann kam so etwas mit
christliche menschenbild und so weiter
und da gab es als ein einziger aufschrei
in ihrer umgebung wenn sie das sagen
brauchen sie gar nicht erst anzutreten
so und dann hat dies aber sehr kluge
berater diesen satz erfunden
übrigens solche berater hatte armin
laschet nie hat er angeboten bekommen
aber nicht genommen man zieht daraus was
daraus wird ja man kann sich gar nicht
genug intelligenz holen und was merkel
angeht
die ist wie helmut kohl gewesen in der
hinsicht sie hat jeden der in frage kam
ihr nachzufolgen weggebissen das fing
mit friedrich merz an ganz tiefe
feindschaft nicht gut verstehen kann
weil er in einer unverschämten weise
über sie geredet hat als ostdeutsche
frau ganz unverschämt damit wäre wenn
das heute mal bekannt würde wäre sofort
erledigt und zwar für alle zeiten dazu
die zweite war hkk kramp karrenbauer die
gedacht hat wenn sie parteivorsitzende
ist dauert so ein halbes jahr dann wird
sie auch kanzlerin das war ein schwerer
irrtum und die hat sich merkel zur brust
genommen hat er gesagt ich höre das mich
stürzen du kannst ja mal versuchen das
war die drohung da ist sie so
erschrocken dass sie gleich in der welt
am sonntag
zurückgezogen hat und dann hat sich auch
noch laschet sich zur brust genommen
könnt ihr euch erinnern an die sendung
bei anne will gegen seine politik los
gezogen die runde beenden und ich finde
ja 16 jahre kanzlerin sie hatten nicht
alles nur schlecht gemacht wir wollen
jetzt nicht mit einem märkischen kreis
ich finde jeder von uns könnte bevor wir
übergeben ein nächsten mal eine nette
sache sagen es kann ja auch was ganz
einfach ist ein jens steiner ich bin für
den humor ich bin auch ein fan von ihrem
humor films okay der humor uli eine
nette sache muss zu sagen dass da fällt
man sieht sofort nichts ein die hatte
früher auch ja aber dem humor stand auch
eine fähigkeit du musst so gemeint dann
sage ich halt mal sie hat gerne
frikadellen mit kartoffelsalat gegessen
gut sebastian einen interessanten und
wenn sie ins büro kam kannst du mir hat
sie gerne die schuhe weggeschleudert
sehr menschliche geste okay
eine nette sache über angela merkel
ich würde sagen es war
sie hat sich jetzt von der außen
betrachtung her in der eu für viel
stabilität gesorgt
gut darüber ließe sich
die allüren losigkeit die alle soll an
ihm schätzen die ist echt da ist nichts
von unterdrückten show gehabe oder weil
sie ist einfach geradlinig und ohne
großen glamour und das ist zum teil
wirklich sehr sympathisch und eines
wollen wir bitte nicht vergessen 2008
hat sie eine rede in der knesset
gehaltenen israel hat sich klar als
staatsraison zur freundschaft mit israel
und zur unterstützung israels bekannt
das hat damals aufsehen erregt das ist
einer der großen ich finde einer der
wenigen aktivposten der wirklich bleibt
auch wenn man nicht genau weiß wie das
ausgefüllt wird aber das zu formulieren
ist durchaus ein verdient
[Musik]